muy buenos días pues ese voto Está
programado para las cuatro de la tarde
hora local Así que todavía Estamos a
unas tres horas de ese voto que como
usted bien lo decía pues va a ser el
momento en que se sepa si pasa o no
alguna de estas dos mociones de censura
una por el grupo eliot que tiene de
hecho el apoyo de izquierda y que en
realidad podría ser la que más votos
saque porque incluso los diputados de
reagrupación nacional el partido de
extrema derecha Ya indicaron que ellos
bien van a apoyar esa moción de censura
pero cuando se hace ya toda un cálculo
de la cantidad de votos que se necesitan
son 287 para que sea aprobada Pues
digamos que van a quedarse cortos entre
unos 20-25 votos esto a pesar de que hay
varios diputados de los republicanos el
partido de derecha que de hecho ayudó a
que esta reforma fuera votada en el
senado que han ido diciendo que también
estarán dispuestos a votar a favor de
esta moción de censura ahora qué es lo
que viene para el gobierno este fin de
semana el Eliseo hizo llegar a la prensa
un comunicado por parte de Manuel
presidente que dice que bien espera y
desea que esta reforma pensional pues
llegue a a término a todo este término
legislativo a lo largo que ha llegado
Pues que ha tomado todo este comienzo de
año aquí en París diciendo que es el
respeto de la Democracia pero ustedes
bien saben que la situación está con
muchísima atención desde el jueves
cuando se aprobó En todo caso por
decreto a esa reforma aquí alrededor de
la asamblea nacional hay muchísima
presencia policial las estaciones sean
de metro y de trenes de cercanías han
sido cerradas y hay muchísima presencia
policial porque se espera que haya
también una manifestación espontánea
como las Ha habido desde efectivamente
el pasado jueves y las Ha habido a lo
largo de todo este fin de semana en
cuanto a qué más puede hacer el gobierno
por ahora Pues lo que esperan es
precisamente que el gobierno se mantenga
eso sería así una victoria digamos
pírrica para el gobierno pero pone de
todas maneras en dificultad de Manuel
para lo que sigue de su quinquenio más
cuando es su digamos su popularidad va
en capa caída ahora para la izquierda
también todavía quedan algunas opciones
una de ellas es presentar un recurso
ante la Corte constitucional para que
evalúe si es o no constitucional en todo
caso toda toda esta ley pero en realidad
ya son muy pocas cosas a las que quedan
y ahora es esperar lo que pase el día de
hoy pero por ahora todo lo que se
pronostica es que no pase esta ninguna
de estas dos emociones de censura y
mientras tanto continúan los bloqueos
especialmente en las refinerías de el
país ya hay un poco de desabastecimiento
de combustible especialmente en el
suroeste del país cerca del 18% en esa
región cuatro por ciento de las
estaciones de servicio en todo el país
tienen algún problema de abastecimiento
y sobre todo en estas refinerías de
donde no están y entrando ni saliendo
ningún tipo de combustible no está
entrando además ningún tipo
de de producto digamos de petróleo para
ser refinado Porque además el aeropuerto
de esto es en el norte del país está
haciendo también bloqueado y mientras
tanto continúan también otras huelgas
como las de las basuras aquí en Francia
aquí en París Perdón así como también en
el sistema de transporte público
especialmente en los trenes en todo el
país y en los aeropuertos